[Music]
we text around you with seeing AI the
first seeing AI channel is short text
and like the name suggests we can use
this for reading text in our environment
you'll be surprised just how many things
have writing on and seeing AI can
instantly read any not handwriting but
any standard text the ability for
computers to read text using OCR has
been around for many years but what
makes this unique is the way that it
starts reading straight away a simple
example here I have two envelopes for me
and a colleague but I don't know which
is mine so I'm just going to take one of
these envelopes and put it under the
camera annular cow cool so as you heard
it said Anna Reed Cole who is my
colleague so that's not my envelopes so
just to make sure let's also try the
other one
I can't shake cool bad pronunciation but
yes that's that's mine netowrk quite
well sometimes however you may find that
the app doesn't read all the text that
might be because you're off to the side
or bit too close so you should try
moving the phone around until you get
all the text in view also this works
best for shorter amounts of text where
it can all be in view at once if you
want to read a whole document then we
have a different channel for that and
talking of documents I wonder what's
inside the envelope Microsoft logo
appears